well I am curious though so Andy so you
listened to that interview recently last
night you've been on the podcast since
then though yeah you came on again
have a yeah yes it's like you
deliberately wanted you just wanted to
hear yourself apologize then too you
might have oh my God already apologize
we've probably had this conversation
already what was the second one about
um I don't know I don't know but I
didn't know that I thought I was only on
the one time no you've been on you you
had already made up for the first one
right oh good and we have you booked for
August to apologize
but you know that was the the first one
was supposed to be about remotes which
we got to do after about 45 minutes yeah
of me of me working things out and and
the first thing I said about the remotes
is I don't remember lots
and that's why doing this podcast
there's so much
stuff that I just don't um I'm sure it's
a blur yeah I mean it's a blur for me we
learn it sometimes as we're
like we had Michael Gordon on the other
day about
that time he ran down the um Jennifer
Garner was on and she corrected Conan's
diction and in my memory Michael Gordon
ran down the stairs with a dictionary
and ran it out to Conan and he corrected
and it was you know a big moment and so
we had him on and he's like oh I ran out
I ran to the staircase and in front of
me already with the same dictionary was
Brian McCann oh what it was Brian McCann
who beat him and I totally forgot that
great part of the story yeah it's hard
to remember all these deals well it's
even the the one that and I mean it's
alarming at times
is there was one and it was just really
striking to me and I kind of vaguely
remembered this circumstances but there
used to be a bus that would go out to
the Hamptons on the weekends right that
was a beauty shop the Jitney yeah no no
this is the beauty right this was like a
beaut a mobile beauty shop so you could
get a mani pedi or your hair done uh and
show up and go to the beach already
and it's like me it's you know and you
did that as a remote yeah like a seven
or eight segment yeah I remember a
segment of going out and I must have
gone out
and then got in a car and you know
probably the whoever was following me in
a passenger van and come back absolutely
no recollection no memory of it and yet
there's video footage and yet there's
videos
the same thing can happen
where there are like like ridiculous
costumes that I'm in and I'm like I
don't remember maybe that's intentional
it must have taken 40 no I think it's
just so many of the especially in the
old days so many of the bits that we
would do
um
it'd be like you know we need you
downstairs at 1 30. to do this bit okay
and I might have kind of glanced at the
bit and then you know everything's
shorts It's not like there's any
memorization go down and it's like oh
here's your Imelda Marcos costume okay
dude and talking about other things that
are going on and you put on the mail
tomorrow get the makeup on and then go
out and shoot it and you know and it
takes 10 minutes to shoot it and then
you take off all the and you go to
rehearsal and it's just
you know it's all just part of the day
and then it would get cut in rehearsal
yeah no one would ever see it yeah or it
would air that night and you're already
moving on to the next day yes exactly it
was five nights a week back then it was
it was and it was yeah and like I say
you
there was it was so there was such a
high volume of stuff that you know I I
mean it you know the Imelda Mark I mean
I just say amount because I I there was
an Imelda Market yeah yeah and um and
and I but you know it's like when you're
doing it you just kind of you know
there's cute cards like it's performing
goes you're not supposed to learn the
lines yeah it's the deal with cue cards
yeah you just go in and do the thing and
you know it's very in the moment and you
don't devote a lot of
you certainly aren't like thinking about
your character no you just well I think
that's probably I mean you're I think
you're touching on something that made
you so good at what you did on the show
is that you were very present in it you
weren't thinking too far in advance
about like oh I'm gonna you know have
these quips you were just in the moment
and improvising and responding I always
felt especially later during the TBS
years
I and I would say to Conan I said people
want to see you and me spending an hour
together and people coming over they
want to experience this hour that you
and I are experiencing so we need to be
with it in this hour and being ourselves
and that was and I always wanted to kind
of
have fun because I felt like it was
important for me to ha if I had fun
within that hour yeah then it would be
fun to watch as opposed to
sweating and worrying about how is this
going to be perceived by the audience it
just seemed you know I mean that was
what rehearsal was for yeah and even
then
I mean right no you were always that I
feel like the red light never phased you
like you were always just from the
beginning right able to put that up that
part out of it just yourself and you
would always come across as very kind of
relaxed thank you yeah yeah no you're
just hanging out in Conan's garage yes
well yeah I mean there was
I mean I also too you know I had it's a
difference of Personality too and and I
had done a lot of improv a lot more
improv than he you know he had done a
lot more writing and TV producing than I
had but I had done I had a lot more
stage time than he did like we talked a
little bit in in the one that I listened
to about how I got the job and so much
of it is me is Robert Smiggle going why
don't you go sit next to him during Test
shows okay hey we're gonna do the live
shows uh you know you want to be the
sidekick sure and then you know them
getting me one sport coat and a tie and
doing those but never thinking
too much about
like like this is my big chance yeah and
we got it was so funny to me that uh
I told the story about Conan and I
during Test shows
being told leave your clothes on you're
going to have dinner with Lauren and
then showing up and Lauren was there
with Steve Martin and it was just the
four of us yeah yeah eating dinner yeah
eating dinner as we're about to start a
show and then the next day Jeff said to
me Jeff Ross said to me something like
well I guess you got the job because I
had to pass Lauren's okay yeah and I was
like Oh I thought I thought I already
had the job
I didn't realize I was that it was
interviewing yeah I didn't realize that
I was auditioning it's probably good you
didn't know yeah yeah and I think well
that was smart not to say anything and
it was well and that was that was I mean
it's not like that was a designed thing
or that I was naive because then I I
knew like oh that was it's good I didn't
know and that's the way I'm gonna
continue to be